technological advancements are changing
the prospects for employment at an
unprecedented speed things that just
five years ago were done by humans are
now done by machines and code the long
term benefits are probably positive as
things will likely become cheaper and
we'll have more time for leisure until
then individuals not prepared for the
changes may be replaced by machines get
laid off or take pay cuts to figure out
if your job will be affected MIT
economist David autor defined three
questions you should ask yourself first
will technology complement or replace
the job you provide computers can't
think for themselves but they can and
will do jobs that follow clear rules so
programmers can tell them what to do
therefore people employed in jobs that
can be programmed away will be driven
out of work or find themselves in less
paying positions on the other hand
people that use technology to become
more productive will hold on to their
positions and even see a raise in income
second is the demand for the product or
service you help provide elastic if you
run a cleaning service in a city were
most people still mop their own floors
technology might help you offer your
services more efficiently the resulting
lower prices makes your serve is
suddenly more attractive to low income
households and the additional demand
creates new jobs however if you work in
the kitchen of a noodle shop empire
there will be a point at which no matter
how efficient you make the noodles
people won't buy an additional bowl they
are full therefore the quantity demanded
for food is not very elastic and a more
efficiency will not create more jobs but
rather the opposite
third can you easily be replaced by
other people if your job is easy to
learn and can be done by others then you
will feel pressure on your wages but if
you are highly skilled or you possess
unique character strengths and there
will be less competition for your
position thus offering you job security
and a stable income until societies
implement good models to share the
wealth and the leisure time that
technological advances will bring us the
most creative problem-solvers and
adaptive team players will reap the
fruits of an uncertain future children
that start school today will look for a
job in 20 years what do you think what
jobs will most likely disappear in your
community and how should schools and
parents prepare their kids to do
meaningful work then
you